hey guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Randy price we're gonna check out
from dark five today you know
Halloween's coming up Halloween's coming
up so I figured five most horrifying
Halloween murders done pretty [__]
scary I feel oh ha benign I'd stood for
10 year old Timothy treating Pixies
though never eat a pixie stick again I
love
what was wrong with the pixi strong
potassium cyanide what the [__] how'd
that get in there oh my god no
he murdered his own kid
I keep we handed it out I mean both
protesters gathered here in sugar tree
you Killer prophet massacred
how you get I mean it's just good Tipler
environmentalist driven insane by LSD
good three disco arson
so Jesus
I want whenever link of it does my Tiger
told yourself
Wow
for now on everyone gets into a
Halloween party and helping please pass
the pima home
I don't want Halloween to come around
such a darkness holiday man oh Jesus
Wow
five years five years that's it five
years to life how am I eligible
house
subscribe subscribe sorry box oh man
okay the one that honestly shocked me
the most was the first one they said the
piggy sticks Pixy Pixy sticks
yeah the pixie straw stuff all that put
a horrible thing to do to you like took
out life insurance policies then you
murder your own kids so you could get
the money for like how [__]
disturbing was this guy even diagnosed
with like some type of illness or was he
just he was just desperate oh my god it
made it sound like he was hanging them
out to everybody not just his own kids
yeah like when people were doing tribute
reading he was handing it out so he was
like you know I wasn't just not one kid
yeah made them sick at least but the kid
with them left he probably like oh I'm
gonna get a ton of them and fill them
all and then when all the remaining ones
like you I feel like there had to have
been some kind of disorder though
because it's very sick yeah I don't
imagine like he did it was like totally
okay with what he did like there's got
to be other he was really haunted by it
or he was like [__] skits as I noticed
in a lot of these crimes I see a Pathan
does not be able to feel yeah the [__]
wouldn't marry that guy or sleep with
him I don't know well I mean I'm sure
lots of sociopaths have sex how do you
think I got Veronica yeah I mean the
stories of parents kill their own kids
those are the ones that really gets me
the most if you guys are suspecting that
your parents are gonna kill you I say
kill them first you can get a punch
justjust leave just a hunch of it just
like a little pinch of suspicion get a
little pinch of suspicion I say act on
it immediately don't do it these are the
words of Ryan right this video makes me
really scared of Halloween because
there's I've been seeing so many of
these like dark five videos lately I'm
thinking about like man the Halloween
really is a night that is so dark that
people might get lost like in the
darkness of it all the high school
murder I mean the when the high school
building I caught on fire because for
teenagers weren't allowed to get in so
they caused the fire
the discotheque does it discotheque um
not appropriate I feel like if four kids
didn't get into a Christmas party I
don't feel like there would have bill
those in clients it pulls something so
dark oh I think they probably you think
so yeah well if they were Christians on
Christmas I'm never gonna do it you're
gonna do it yes sir gather together yeah
Halloween just seems like a time where
people get so lost in darkness and stuff
and they like indulge in darkness that I
feel like they're more likely to commit
acts of crime because it's more
forgiving yeah I don't know about
forgivable but it's more than you know
more tempting I think or more a lot more
fat fascinating to give into such a
thing you know it's a little strange I
like these always agree all these
murders occurred directly on Halloween
and you know it's like though there
seemed to be some type of horror thing
linked to this is a situation you know
that we could probably watch one that
had to do with Christmas and have all
these weird things I'm trying to say
that video games cause people to kill
people but what do you I don't know I I
mean I'm trying to take a stance I
figured you know I should take some type
of political stance here do it alright
okay I'm ready for it the Republicans
are right right that's the cool thing
sick they're the ones for gay marriage
right totally yeah
Joan rabble so he was involved with a
girl he's mad girl was involved with a
guy and that guy killed him I don't know
what all the particulars are but it
seemed to me like he wasn't or she was
involved with him and his wife in a love
triangle type of thing his rabble is the
one that convicted or convinced him to
kill her husband right okay cuz those
two were sentenced were the ones that
were sentenced
I know murder is not only a current
Halloween but for some reason I feel
like Halloween was a specific date for
these guys to actually do these murders
oh we could just act like
trick-or-treaters and then do this you
know like kill them this one definitely
because it was after 11:00 p.m. and he's
like Oh who's at the door so he yeah
answer it and then a three-shot don't
get in love right right through the
heart you don't get it
of triangles yeah dumped when Roenick
and I were in love triangle some of the
hottest days of our life black man named
Tyrone man oh yeah that one where the
kid came home and found his like family
dead like and he thought it was a prank
yeah that's so what if he uh what if he
thought it was a prank for like three
hours he would be that dense I know but
I'm imagine he like goes home he's like
all right guys I'm gonna walk in the
other room now when you guys were ready
to stop pulling this joke
I'll be watching television and then he
just waits for a few hours
then he opens the door again three hours
later and there's still there and he's
like okay you guys are really trying to
make the place smell there's this corn
syrup everywhere you guys need to stop
close the door
next day you got a guy signing Halloween
anymore stop it
that's longer than three hours I know
this went on for about 24 hours before
he realized they were actually dead no
no this isn't a good joking topic now
because it's real so I should have made
fun of something real well that's what
the Democrats would do the idea is just
to make me look like I've been sensitive
and that I'm stupid at the same time so
I can get away with the insensitivity
hey I think it's working just like the
Republican hey guys what we're
discussion after the video if you're new
to the channel subscribe today and
become rejected no just rejects just
become a reject hashtag I'm a real
reject I like that one actually a
hashtag that then you could hashtag
Brandi Oh Andy
what one - tag baseline beatnik but be
nick is a perso type of person Tina what
is that what kind of person is that
it's someone that can rejects
conventional behaviors like a real
reject yeah kind of mm-hmm
stealing okay Eric and you could follow
us on Facebook Instagram Twitter I have
a vine in periscope and let's do a shout
out to a person who really deserves it
Cornell Murray the real rejects
bro I love your channel me and my sister
watch you
Tyron Gator aqus on and all the reactors
everyday keep it up Oh may I have a
shout-out
listen Cornell I don't care that you
watched Tyrone Gator aqus on and all the
other reactors because guess what
there's like fifty six reactors now okay
there's too many of them yeah
I want to prove something to you I want
to tell you something okay I actually
take the time to try to scuzz the video
afterwards so it's Brandi with her
videos most reactors they react two
seconds later subscribe you look at us
we got lights we got a professional
camera got a microphone
this is [__] set here saying some
things some like living room background
or something this is is an actual set I
mean mines a living room yeah yeah yeah
get get a set live up to the part of me
the fact that you're saying you watch me
and then all these other [__]
know it's not cool don't watch my
channel anymore I don't want you to
watch Channel core now cuz I'm better
than you I'm better than them I'm not
better than Tyrone or gaiter Martin or
jinx
or acha song or brandy
he made him cry
you made him cry because you asked for a
shout-out what's wrong with you SiC ping
compared to all these [__] people I'm
sick of being in the same category as
all these reactors turn off the camera
man [__] you